uh thank you members uh good evening
members officers and members of the
public I don't think we have any press
here
um welcome to this planning committee
meeting on the 21st of September I will
remind members that you are being live
streamed on the council's YouTube
channel
uh just a little point for myself
um
obviously
most of us have had quite a sad time
with the news we've heard over the last
couple of weeks
but on a lighter note and I hope members
don't mind me saying this we have a
member of this committee tonight who is
celebrating his 50th birthday
sorry Horace but it's canceled as shrubs
50th birthday so I think all of us we're
not going to sing Happy Birthday I'll
show you that um
um
yeah I know
many happy returns and I think that's
from all of us Horace and I'd just like
to know what it's like to be 50 you know
okay at some stage
I will find out thank you
I know who my friends are don't worry um
housekeeping uh if the fire fire alarm
is activated please vacate the offices
via the stairs either through the
security door to my right
um and uh obviously in the foyer where
you came in but please do not use the
lifts please assemble on holy Square on
the green and officers will assist you
advise you when it is deemed safe to
return here into the chamber
uh does anybody here this evening intend
to film the meeting
no thank you very much
the Restriction of mobile phones I would
ask everybody present please ensure
their mobile phones are turned to silent
and they do not use them or make or
receive calls in this chamber while this
meeting is going ahead
there are a couple of items which have
been withdrawn tonight and that is items
for B and 4C
and number 18 Eastern Esplanade Margate
the wishing Towers a property
we've come to that in a few minutes
um members wishing to speak under 24
sorry 20.1 are there any members here
this evening
no thank you for that so uh public
speaking if members could make a note on
public speaking
item 4A Eddington House business center
in Addington Place Ramsgate item 4D
Richmond energy Park sandwich Road
Ramsgate item 4E 54 watt Stone Road
brawl says and item 4G
josgap road again in broadstairs
a gender item one apologies for absence
I have apologies for councilman Moore
and councilor Wallin is a substitute and
thank you Council of all in I also have
apologies for councilor roseski are
there any other apologies
no
thank you
gender item two Declarations of Interest
are there any Declarations of Interest
thank you members
agenda item three the members agree that
the meeting of the planning committee
which was held on the 17th of August of
2022 be approved as a correct record
could I have a proposal please
councilor Hart a seconder Council Auburn
to members degree
thank you members
gender item 4 schedule of planning
applications if there are any site
visits from tonight's meeting they will
take place on the 7th of October 2022
on this point I'm going to hand over to
Mr Livingston for what a point of
information
thank you
thank you chair
um point of information on two schedule
items for G uh Josh Gap Road and uh for
J
um garages at Tomlin drive so for 4G
um further clarification has been sought
with regards to railings to be provided
as part of the proposal and confirmation
has been given that the height of these
ratings will be one meter in height
members will see the plans to show the
location of the railings it's proposed
by officers the description of
development is updated and that the
following condition is added as
condition five to the recommendation and
the condition would read prior to the
installation of the black railings here
by approved design details of the
ratings shall be submitted to an
approved in writing by the local
planning Authority the development shall
be carried out in accordance with the
approved details and the ground of that
is in the interests of visual amenities
of the area and to adequately integrate
the development into the environment
uh the point of information with regards
to Four J carriages at Tomlin Drive
since the publishing of the committee
agenda we have received a construction
Environmental Management plan a
demolition statement and an asbestos
survey which was requested by the
Environmental Health Department of of
the council and they've been
subsequently assessed by the council's
environmental health Team this has been
considered sufficient and environmental
health has satisfied that the details
provided cover the issues raised in the
conditions and therefore condition one
which required the submission of these
details prior to the commencement of the
demolition would be amended to read the
development should be carried out in
accordance with the details within the
construction Environmental Management
plan demolition method statement and the
actions within the asbestos survey
received on the 20th of September and
the construction Environmental
Management plan was in the members box
for information as well thank you chair
thank you Ian agenda item for a this has
public speaking uh Addison House
business center Addington Place Ramsgate
speaking in favor of the application is
Mr John gold is Mr Gold with us
thank you Mr Gold you have three minutes
thank you
thank you for the opportunity to give
you a brief recent history of the
property known as Addington House
business center a large commercial
building subdivided into smaller offices
and workshops that in recent years have
been mostly empty the demand for
Backstreet commercial space all but gone
due to the nice new shiny business
centers built at manston our application
for eight residential units all with
parking which utilize this building
while maintaining the historic Flint
features in its walls and with hardly
any disruption to The Wider community
as this building is centered around the
courtyard the visual appearance of the
surrounding area would not change but
its immediate neighbors will have the
benefit of the Regeneration of the
structure and the reassurance of its
future
we have in our designs sought to return
the property to how it would have looked
when it was built and reversed the many
alterations carried out over the years
with a conservation officer commenting
on this application that the choice of
materials is better than what's there
now
a refusal of this application would
through throw into question what this
property would then be of use for
already turned down for houses no longer
a commercial asset it would ultimately
become derelict with all that would
entail squatters graffiti a dangerous
structure and ultimately demolition
anyway
but only after years of problems and for
the thriving community that this
property sits in in the heart of a
Conservation Area thank you
thank you very much for scold I now ask
the planning officer to outline the
report and my that is Emma thank you
thank you chairman
all right
see the the existing building shape
um in the colored sort of brown so you
can see Hartford place
um to the north of the site and added
some place to the south of the site and
you can see there's a an internal
Courtyard space behind the building
which is um current users parking
so this is a aerial view of the site so
again you can see the existing L-shaped
building on the site that's currently
used for um commercial office and
storage use and you can see the focal
area in front of that space that's used
for parking and the access into the site
that leads from Addington place
and then just another view again of the
building so you can see it's a two-story
building most the windows are internal
facing to that courtyard space
and then this is the view more from the
Hartford place looking towards the
building so again you can see on the
Northern elevation it's quite a blank
elevation with just two existing first
floor Windows looking out into Hartford
place and it's straight onto onto the
road Edge and again you can see
um the the focal area in this area here
for parking and this existing
Residential Properties fronting onto
Addington Place opposite the building
so these are some views now from the
surrounding area so this view is from
Hartford place looking towards the
building so this is the the building
here so you can see the existing first
floor Windows
um you can see that there's some Flint
within the elevation which if members
recall when this previously went to
committee there was um some sort of this
was raised as a something that would be
useful to be seen retained so as part of
this application it is the retention of
this building the retention of this
Flint wall within this elevation
and this is then taken from inside the
site so the internal focal area that's
currently used for parking looking
towards the elevations that are
currently served so the majority of the
windows into the units so the proposal
doesn't involve
um some alterations of these windows
where some would turn into doors and
there's some introduction of some
additional cladding materials and you
can see that the windows at the moment
are upvc and the application proposes
that these would change to some form of
metal so either aluminum or Crystal
this again you can see is the building
here this is an existing single story
projection that comes out from the
building so the proposal does include a
first for extension above this building
so this is the neighboring property
number four Hartford place so this is
the um the closest neighboring property
that could be affected by the extension
so again you can see in this location
here would be the extension the
extension doesn't exceed the height of
the existing building so whilst it is an
additional floor being added in this
location because of this style of roof
that's on the single story projection
which is like a mono pitch roof with
this point here being the highest point
the first raw Edition increases the
height by only 1.4 meters in this
location so the height of the extension
would be below the first floor window of
the neighboring property
you can see that there's a production
access that runs between the neighboring
property and the site and you can also
see the ground level change as well
between the the buildings
um this is just a closer view just so
you can see the rear of the neighboring
property so the closest opening to the
extension is a door and then you can see
that there's a window next to this this
is the walkway here and you can see the
heart of the boundary treatment so in
terms of when we look at the first
extension in terms of looking at the
impacts of light and Outlook there's
this distance of 1.2 meters here and
then the closest opening being a door
that would be affected
then these are the properties opposite
the internal elevation so you can just
see there's some Residential Properties
that face it but there's no private
immediate space to the front of these
properties and again just views of the
existing building as we move around
and now coming into adding some play so
this is the existing access vehicular
access that leads into the site and this
would also continue to provide access
for parking to serve this building
and you can see this is the existing
site elevation onto Addington place so
the proposal does involve knocking
through part of this wall to create the
Refuge storage to serve the development
and then this is again the building here
so you can see this is existing
elevation with four windows that face
onto the neighboring garage site
um as part of The Proposal is intended
to retain these windows but concern
um was raised from environmental health
about the impact from the garage on the
living conditions of the the occupiers
of these Flats
um and therefore it is considered that
these should be fixed and acoustic
glazing used and also obscure graze in
order to limit any impact on the future
occupiers of this unit from the garage
and here again you can see the
neighboring garage so this is a adjacent
to the building and so therefore these
these windows are conditioned in order
that noise from the garage would not
affect the the future occupiers
and then this again is just taken from
adding to place looking towards the
building which is in this location here
with the vehicular access in this point
here and you can see this is the the
other elevation of those
um Residential Properties that are
opposite the um the internal elevation
of the building
so this is a block plan of the um
building so the existing building is
being retained the only external
alterations are the erection of this
first floor extension which is in this
location here so you can see this is the
location of number four Hartford place
and again you can see the the side
pedestrian access between the buildings
and you can see the depth of the
extension which is just solely above the
existing single story extension and
other than this the only external
alteration are to some windows within
the elevation
so this is the existing ground floor
plan so the existing building is is in
commercial use and you can see that
there's staff parking to the front of
this building
and this is the proposed ground floor
plan
so the application is for
um a change of use of the building to
create eight Flats three are three bed
three or two bed and two are one bed
units
um you can see here in terms of the
parking layout there's eight parking
spaces so providing one space per
residential unit this achieves maximum
parking standards given that is Edges
Town Center location
um so the only the only issue raised by
um highways was the fact that visitor
parking wasn't provided but they've they
consider that because it is such a
sustainable location and Edge of the
Town Center that that's not a reason to
raise any any real concerns on highway
safety grounds
in terms of the flats they all meet
um the naturally described space
standards there's a condition requiring
that there would be details of the
clothes drying um provision to be
submitted and in terms of The Refuge
that's in this location here so again
that end elevation that was on to add
into place this would be not through to
create the the refuse storage and the
the waste department are happy that the
space is adequate to to serve the refuse
size needed to serve the units and
they're also happy that there's there is
a refuge collection that runs down this
road that would be able to collect from
the site
um you can see within this area here
there's a turning space that would
provide turning for the parking spaces
and in this location here with cycle
parking so there's cycle parking
internally within some of the units and
where you would put the the bike up
against the wall but this is the
external
um cycle parking which would also
provide some space for Vista spaces as
well
also electric vehicle charging has been
provided so each space will have an
electric vehicle charging point
um this is the existing first floor and
this is proposed first floor so again
you could just see um the flats
um there's very few changes in terms of
the windows on the Northern side in a
minute you'll see that there's just the
one additional window being added and
then in this extension here you can see
there's some internal Windows into the
courtyard space being added but no
windows on the elevation face in the
neighboring property
so this is the front elevation so this
is the internal elevation into the
courtyard space as as it is existing and
then this is how it is proposed so you
can see there's a few windows that are
changing to create French doors with
balconets
um there's a few windows that are our
doors are becoming windows and in those
locations some Timber cladding is being
used on the elevation which does add
some interest to the elevation and you
can see on the left hand side here this
is the first floor extension that's been
proposed and so windows are being
proposed within that end Innovation the
extension will be of bricks to match the
existing bricks on the building and then
on the right hand side here you can see
the opening for The Refuge store within
that existing elevation
so again as mentioned earlier all of the
windows and doors are being replaced are
being replaced with either aluminum or
crittle which is considered to be an
enhancement within the Conservation Area
this is the existing rear elevation so
the elevation facing onto Hartford place
so you can see there's just the existing
first floor windows and you can see the
Flint element within the wall and this
is the proposed elevation so the only
addition is this ground floor window
which again is going to be in aluminum
or Crystal
this is the elevation facing the garage
so the neighboring garage that you saw
with within the photo so they're the
existing windows and that's the proposed
so again no actual changes but the
condition that's been added is to
restrict these windows to make sure they
don't open and they have adequate
acoustic glazing to prevent any impact
from the garage on the future occupiers
this is the existing site elevation
facing number four Hartford place so
this is the location of the proposed
first for extension and then this is the
proposed extension so you can see the
height of the extension follows the
lowest part of the existing building and
you can just see it's just going to be
brickwork similar depth to the existing
ground floor elevation
and so in terms of the design there's a
few concerns regarding the impact on the
conservation area in terms of the the
rear extension it's not going to be
overly visible because it's internal
within the courtyard space so there's
not really going to be any wider views
of that first for extension and in any
case the extension appears in keeping
with the existing building and his
materials to match the existing building
in terms of the impact on the neighbors
um the impact on number four Hartford
place is consider that there's a
sufficient Gap to the property and given
the fact it's only a 1.4 meter
um increase in height and the fact that
the nearest opening is the door that
there won't be um significant impacts on
lighter Outlets to that property in
terms of all other impacts on neighbors
the ground floor window on the site um
on the elevation face in Hartford place
would not result in any overlooking
given the fact it's ground floor level
and all of the other openings are are
existing so there's no additional impact
from these
um
highways as mentioned have raised no
concerns in terms of the impact on the
highway safety and therefore it's
considered to be a good reuse of the
building in a sustainable location
um a legal agreement's been submitted
securing the spa contribution and
therefore it is recommended for approval
thank you
thank you Ella I recommend the officers
recommendation which is to approve the
vice chair please second I'll second
nature thank you uh Council comma cook
members
I think it's a very good use of space
actually my only concern is those
windows that are going over the garage
um it's supposed to be closed and sound
proof uh is there any way of getting
fresh air into the top of that building
thank you
yes
um they they are secondary windows so so
if I just show you
so this is the first floor plan so those
windows are on this right hand elevation
here so one of them serves a lounge but
it has two windows on the other side of
the elevation so there's three Windows
serve in that room so these could open
um on this side here and the other
windows are just serving the hallway
space so again it's not really essential
for those to be opened and it's all
quite open plan leading into the lounge
so there would be sufficient ventilation
to serve that flap
thank you Emma Council bateford
thank you chair I agree with councilor
Hart I think it's an excellent use of
space providing eight a ffordable units
which we very very badly need
um one of the concerns is that the units
are too small well they uh meet the
requirements and if we want housing to
be affordable it isn't going to be grand
and huge I very much I think this has
been well thought out and I would like
to support this application thank you
thank you Council Keane
thank you
um I know it's been conditioned but do
we have any idea what the clothes drying
facilities would be
um because it does say here about could
be a tumble dryer within the units or
airing cupboards and I'm just thinking
of the cost of living and electricity
that is is there any other options for
drying facilities
and also
um the two options we usually look at
are the tumble dryers or airing carpets
would be the other option which they
could then just show on a plan of where
they're going to incorporate an
additional cupboard potentially
um so yeah usually they would normally
be the only two options unless there's
some external space which there isn't
for this particular scheme so it usually
if they if they submit a tumble dryer or
a floor plan showing where airing covers
would go we usually consider that to be
okay
thank you Council Robin yes thank you
chair
um I think we should give the developer
credit
for listening to what was said at the
last in the last application was brought
to us it was over development they give
it some serious different thoughts and
come up with this and I think this is
well suited on on on this site and I'm
happy to support your chair thank you uh
thank you Council wing
neck of the wood very well I'd just like
to point out that the garage has
actually been shut for some time now
about six months so maybe we need to
allow and I do understand that there's a
planning application going into that bit
which maybe enables the developer here
to rethink the the windows being
permanently shut so that's just a minor
tweak but uh yeah the concern was over
development lack of parking I was
concerned about the loss of the the
Flint wall which is a unique historical
aspect apparently the flintster level I
know it's like there are bits of it it's
there's history about it so it does look
ugly but it's actually a quite historic
uh significant piece of flint wall again
I think the developer needs to be
congratulated on on listening to what
was said he did come back a second time
particularly but you know he's listened
uh I think this is a really good
development there's plenty of parking
and there should be plenty of space for
people to get in and out I'd just like
to say that as the development proceeds
there and maybe the development it's
such a tight area that we need to
consider the impact of the development
on the local on the local area but I'm
absolutely certain that if the developer
listens to locals then we can and we can
address some of those issues but I like
the electric charging points I like the
ReUse of the building so we're reusing
stuff rather than buying new stuff so I
think it's a it's a partly derelict site
that I think will look a lot Dem site
better thank you uh thank you counseling
Council Everett yeah I'm happy to
support the application I was just a bit
puzzled by the fact that we seem to be
conditioning it two ways for the same
site and we talk about
um obscure glazing because the garage
site might be developed because there's
an application to develop the garage
site for residential and acoustic
glazing because it's a garage
I just wonder what what the logic of
that is and how that works in terms of
the planning system I can see what we're
trying to do but is that a reasonable
thing to do
can you answer it
no
um yeah it has it has been a little
tricky because at the same time we've
got the appeal in as well so I'm having
to consider what what could be on this
site if if that were to come forward
what could be on the neighboring site if
that were to be approved by members
which hopefully should be on the next
agenda
um so yeah the acoustic glazing
um and the fixing shot of the windows
has been put on because of the fact it
is a garage and could even if it is
closed at the moment could continue
because that's its current lawful use
um but yes if it were to come forward as
as something alternative to that then
obscure grazing would
um help in terms of looking towards the
because it's right on the boundary so
looking towards the neighboring site it
would could restrict what could happen
on the neighboring side so the facts
they're non-habitable rooms because it's
just serving the hallway and it's just a
secondary window means there's no
concern really we've put an obscure
grazing in those windows it's not like
the bedrooms that would have no Outlook
so there's no reason why that's that's
harmful and the um the applicant has
even said that they're happy just block
off those windows if they had to because
they don't really need them but they're
there at the moment so we've just
conditioned the glass that will go in it
thank you
any more we should Council Ghana
thank you yeah
um Emma you mentioned and I'd I'd read
there's the appeal
pending on the previous application that
we as a committee uh refused
um can you just clarify do we do we have
any sort of
commitment that if if this application
were to be approved by us is this the
application that would be taken forward
by the developer
um the developer would then have the
option of of carrying out either scheme
so if it was allowed to appeal and I
have no update at all at the moment on
on the appeal but if that were to be
um allowed and members decided to
approve this tonight then the the
developer would basically have two
schemes on the table that he could
Implement either of those two schemes
thank you Emma
um I can't see any other
questions thank you members so now put
this motion to you which is the
officer's recommendation for approval
those in favor
against
abstentions
that is unanimous I think okay carried
thank you members
uh gender item four D which is an
application for approval uh the Richboro
energy Park sandwich Road Ramsgate
we have Mr Alex Patridge I hope I've
pronounced that right speaking in favor
of this application Mr Patrick three
minutes please
teacher members thank you for your time
this evening to consider the provisions
for the ongoing development of Richmond
energy Park
as a core component of the UK's
renewable energy infrastructure the
ritual energy park has a long-standing
history of energy related uses from its
former guys there's a power station
through to its current working
relationship with the Nemo
interconnector and grid connections for
offshore wind as a Brownfield site with
access to the National Grid
it is uniquely situated to continuing
its role in supporting the UK's move
to a sustainable future achieving
through Extinction
of the existing electrical battery
storage facility
nationally the UK has a legally binding
commitment to achieve Net Zero carbon
emissions by 2050. key to this will be
development of a reliable and
sustainable supply of renewable energy
this can only be achieved if there is
the delivery of supporting
infrastructure to compensate for periods
where there'll be a shortfall in the
generation of wind and solar energy to
meet demand
battery storage like that already
permitted and this application for your
consideration today is a tested means of
supporting Renewable Energy Technologies
with minimal environmental impact
as there is no noise emissions and no
emissions arising from the scheme
we acknowledge consultation comments
were raised by Natural England and Kent
County Council on ecological grounds and
note that these have been addressed
through proposed conditions and
mitigation measures
these include the provision of off-site
enhancement and biodiversity rules
that there will also be no adverse
ecological impact and an offer of an
improvement over and above the current
site Communications to safeguard the
neighboring protected sites The Proposal
will allow for the creation of a number
of jobs during its development
as well as some servicing and
maintenance roles post-completion
fundamentally however the contribution
to the UK PLC and a move to a
sustainable future is a key benefit of
this scheme
in assessing this game you're planning
ecology and highways officers have
carefully considered the proposals and
concluded on balance that they are
acceptable and Accord with national
local planning and ecology policies
with no material planning considerations
way into the country
this application has been recommended by
your offices for approval
we hope that you will be able to endorse
the recommendation this evening thank
you very much for your time uh thank you
very much asked Mr Livingston to outline
the report please
thank you chair
um so the application is for a proposed
electrical battery storage facility
including equipment alterations to land
level
and also the removal of the wind turbine
that I think most most people probably
be quite familiar with at ridgeborough
so the site in question this is uh
richborough
um previous site of the towers the site
itself is located on the left-hand side
of the image if you're traveling along
the river star you've got
um
this plan which shows the rich put
energy uh sort of area you've then got
the area in pink and in yellow which are
previous sites of approvals for planning
permission for uh battery storage
facilities so the site itself is
outlined in Red so the hatched red color
so that's a more detailed view of the
site itself so you can see the site
comprises of uh you've got Access Road
into the site you've got
um grassland in the site you've got
landscape boundaries on both the North
and South uh South along with the star
and you can see the wind turbine where
the mouse is here and you've got quite a
bit of hard standing on the site which
is the reference to previously developed
land in this area now in terms of the
site itself though
uh part of the site the right hand side
in this image is within the yellow area
which is the cc07 policy which is the
Richboro policy the ridge for policy is
specifically for that area to be used
for the development of renewable energy
facilities if it can be demonstrated
that development wouldn't harm the
impact on sites of nature conservation
value and that any effects are suitably
assessed
so part of the site is in that
allocation and the rest of the site is
in the countryside so that falls under
the uh the policy test of
um you know assessing the harms of the
countryside and whether or not the
proposed development is Justified in the
countryside location
uh the site also forms on part of a
local Wildlife site which is uh covered
under policy
gio2 which is outlined to basically
cover the area that is the I suppose
lighter green I think it's probably fair
to say of the of the two areas which
this cuts across so it's the grassed
area
which would be lost as part of this
proposal that policy test specifically
allows for loss but only when planting
is in place or suitable mitigation is in
place to offset that loss
um so we're just going to have a little
look at some images of the site now from
the ground so just on the right hand
side is the existing access that goes
all the way through the Richmond site
um sorry to skip through these ones here
so we get to this one
um so this is again a detail via the
site the image in the bottom left hand
corner for people for members is the
access road in so it's an image that
shows the access road in the main image
to be focusing on is the bulk of the
site which is this top image here
um so what is important to note at the
moment is that there are two other masks
other than the turbine there are two
telecommunications masks that are on the
site
um so you've got one which is where the
line comes down and then you've got
another one which is on the left hand
side
so this is the proposed layout
um so I thought the images were a bit
sooner but they're after this image
um so this is the proposed layout of the
facilities themselves so
the main issues to consider as mentioned
are the impact on the countryside so the
principle of development itself impact
on the landscape character area because
we're in the countryside it's the style
marshes character area specifically and
predominantly it's the impact on the
environment so as already mentioned um
with regards to impact on biodiversity
including protected species the site
which you can see hatched um in the top
of the image is part of the designated
triple SI site which is the Savage beta
hackling marshes triple SI as well as
the local Wildlife site as well
so this is an image looking straight
into the site from effectively the um
the the East looking to the West so you
can see the big mast in the foreground
you can see the access across uh the
site
so this is then looking back towards
that gate that we were just looking
through so you can see
um this is the area that's got approval
already for battery storage
that's turning to your left from the
previous image so you can see that
there's some
um some Landscaping
um that's that's on the which is the
northern part of the site
and then this is turning back around and
looking down the the access road towards
where the wind turbine is and the the
Mast themselves so you can see that the
the development would be either side of
this Access Road
um in the grassed area that's shown
um with Landscaping on both boundaries
retained where possible you've then so
traveling then back across the site if
you can see the um the the pit with a
mouse pointer is it's the uh The White
Square on the images where the Mast is
this is the first telecommunications
masked we're going to look from there
back towards the
um the the existing battery storage area
so that's the Mast on the right hand
side so we're looking back towards
Richboro from here so again this shows
the span of the site as mentioned the
flat nature of the landscape in this
area
um this is sort of back even further so
you've got the turbine itself and a
single story building and the the area
of hard standing
um the building and the the turbine
itself or the turbine is obviously to be
removed
um
and actually if I just go back there
so the area where um this photo is taken
from is actually in the local Wildlife
site so that grass that's the left-hand
side there is part of that designation
um that I mentioned earlier
um and then this is a view looking from
the left hand side of this image so on
the western extent of the site looking
towards
um the area that's not part of the
application site
um you can see where the mouse pointer
is here is the location of the other
telecommunications Mast
um
which you can see in the sort of almost
the center of the site here and then
you've got
a an existing building which I believe
is used as a sort of bat mitigation
which is not a part of this development
is is to be retained
so
um the battery storage containers
themselves are to be 2.9 meters in
height the development has a substation
on the right hand side of this image so
right at that entrance point where the
gate was that substation includes
predominantly equipment at about 12
meters in height but includes the
potential to go up to 15 meters and
we'll look at a section through that bit
of the site so you can see the
particular impact there one of the
issues that's come through the
application is this has come through the
environment agencies is the potential
risk of flooding on the site you're
obviously next to the star and so the
proposal includes the requirement to
increase the height of the land level to
to three meters above Ordnance datum
level
um that only actually results in a
maximum change in land level of a meter
across the site and it does actually
include some areas to be excavated down
in fact including where the wind turbine
is but we'll show you some sections of
that
so just to show you a few sections so
you can see on the left hand side of the
image you've got the twos on the left
hand side of the image there so just
have a quick look through that section
so the top is a section of the existing
land level and the bottom image is the
reduced land level so it may be a bit
faint but on this bottom image you can
see that there's a dotted blue line
which shows the reduction in land level
there so you can see the sort of pro
form of the containers themselves the
site is to be surrounded by a a four
meter high
green mesh fence which you can see
there's a green line you can see in the
sections which shows that height
um going through then this is a section
the other end of the site so as I
mentioned about the the substation and
the array that's there this is the the
highest part of the development it's
obviously located directly adjacent to
where the existing approvals are for the
battery storage closest to Richboro so
this is in the area that's designated uh
under the renewable energy policy
um
and then
going across the whole site and I had
split this across a few slides so bear
with me Members so the top image is on
the western extent of the site and
you're going all the way through the
size if you're going along the access
road basically so you've got the top
image then moving along the bottom image
and you can see where the existing Mast
is there which is to be retained so you
can see that you've got all these
battery storage units and then moving
along and then there is the the last bit
at the end there which is the the
substation
so these um these storage containers
themselves as mentioned they are um they
have green roofs they've all got
individual fans in them to ensure that
the batteries stay cool
um you've then got a various converter
stations against similar sort of form to
the development of the actual battery
storage containers
and this is similarly uh sort of
functional buildings that are required
on the site and then
bear with me there we go
um
so just to go through some of the issues
that came up during the consultation
um
the the main concern here is the fact
that you are adjacent to Triple SI
it does result in the loss of of some
trees on site and obviously it does
result in a partial loss of part of the
local Wildlife side and that's why
initially you'll see the comments from
Natural England in the report which
raised concerns about potentially the
impact on the triple SI as well as
impact race or concerns raised by KCC
biodiversity
um what was produced was a further
assessment
um of what could be done
um in terms of mitigation it was
considered that the mitigation the
conditions basically requiring a
detailed ecological mitigation package
including habitat improvements which
form part of conditions four and seven
of the proposal have been considered to
be acceptable by both Natural England
and also by KCC biodiversity
um particular condition seven is looking
at actually a management plan to include
not only maps of the mitigation areas
and habitat creation but also detailed
management plans capable of being a
five-year rolling plan because obviously
the key important Point here is that
actually the the habitats are are
maintained as they need to be you've
also got as mentioned condition four
where it includes species surveys as
well that will be required on the site
those have been considered to be
acceptable by now actual England and by
by KCC biodiversity I just want to go
back to show you the aerial image again
to talk about the landscape visual
impact so
in terms of the style marshes landscape
character that is
um predominantly about flat long
distance views across towards both pegel
Bay and the north the site as you'll
have seen from the images has got
screening either side
um it is obviously seen to some extent
in association with the rich precise
obviously it is also also previously
about land in part it's obviously got
some structures on at the moment along
the South Bank of the river star there
is the Saxon Shore way so there was a
public right-of-way which runs along
there so there will be some views
through of some of the battery storage
facilities through the existing
landscape which is being retained on the
Northern Bank of the river star so that
impact has to be weighed up against the
actual proposal itself and obviously
that's what the report is looking to do
in terms of that principle of
development there is significant support
in the mppf and within the local plan
for this type of facility it doesn't
immediately Accord with the renewable
energy policy because it's not
generating renewable energy but it's
obviously giving Security in terms of
the storage of renewable energy and
being able to release that electricity
onto the grid as and when necessary when
Peak demand requires it
um is is clearly of benefit
um both locally and nationally in terms
of the move to renewable forms of energy
and so therefore on that basis even
though there is an impact on a localized
impact on the countryside we consider
with the mitigation that would be
proposed for dealing with the fact that
there will be loss of some habitats on
site and taking account of those
benefits it has been recommended for
approval thank you chair
uh thank you very much Ian
I moved to the office's recommendation
is adopted because the vice chair please
second oh second nature I think
councilman cook members
councilor Garner
thank you
um
well obviously well I think obviously
um battery storage facilities
um certainly if they're linked to our
wind farms uh vital for our future
energy resilience
this is
a very large
battery basically being being created
being built do we have any eye any
commitments as to where the energy is
going to be coming from
that is going to be how the energy is
going to be generated to be stored at
this facility I.E will it be will it be
from the Wind Farm Green energy
I think that's my main question
um I don't have the information exactly
about where it would would come from the
reason why it's located here is because
of the position on the grid um because
obviously of the projects that are
detailed both are in the report in terms
of both the
um the connection to to Belgium known as
the the Nemo project but also the
peaking plant and also the um obviously
very rather large pylons that came
through the Enzo proposal over the years
I'm afraid to say I don't know exactly
that we could automatically guarantee
that it definitely is coming from I
suppose renewable sources uh so to speak
um and and it's
um I suppose it's it's not necessarily a
planning we wouldn't for example be able
to condition where it comes from
effectively so we are acknowledging the
fact that the proposal is according with
the spirit of the policy but it doesn't
Accord directly with that policy because
it isn't generating renewable energy
okay if I could just come come back in
it because okay reading reading the
report I uh one of the
um policies cited in our local plan
um to help support this application is
policy SP 37 which I'll read what's
written here a new development must take
account of the need to respond to
climate change so
so I would say
obviously there are a number of concerns
here in that have necessitate
environmental mitigations because of
where it's been built so good counter to
that would be if we are making sure that
this is enabling us to respond to
climate change that's a good thing and
one of the ways of doing that would be
making sure that this is renewable
energy being stored because if it isn't
renewable energy being stored here then
obviously we're not
particularly take in account of climate
change we're exacerbating it and I think
one of the
one of the concerns linked to that that
I do have is the close close proximity
of the Kent renewable energy biomass
plan just down the road that that's
obviously generating
generating energy that may be wanting to
be stored here which I would find
um very
disquieting knowing that that so-called
renewable energy plant is generating
energy through the through the
destruction of and burning of
many thousands of trees and lots of them
emanating from Eastern European ancient
forests so that's I understand you can't
you can't give a an assurance about that
but I think it that my concern would be
if any energy has been generated there
and stored here we're not tackling
climate change we're exacerbating it
uh thank you Council Garner councilor
Keane
Wing said it again said it again it goes
confused I mean I again I sort of know
this area fairly well uh he's he's on my
dog walking route but uh I do have
concerns that we we we're impacting on a
triple sssi but I'm conflicted because
if it is genuinely story renewed Rene
Noble energy we're desperate to
to diversify that that that that that
facility in this country quite clearly
uh but I I'm just conflicted over the uh
the the use of the use of a triple SSI
area uh and I'm I'm I you know I I just
find it I find it also find it difficult
that it's right next to the river stower
and I was here I've lived in this area
when when that flood came in the big
Northern surge that came down uh the the
the the only coincided with with three
high tides and my friends that live in
Sandwich were a centimeter
a centimeter the environment agent were
brilliant actually they saved that that
low part of sandwich you know obviously
there's been flood defenses have been
put in place but I'm not sure raising
the level of of the land to was it three
meters is going to be enough uh over the
coming years and I'm assuming this this
facilities I don't know what is the
lifespan of this facility
no
um I must I don't know the lifespan of
it it's not it's not been put forward to
indicate that it's anything other than
permanent I think is the point
um just to confirm one of the issues
that was raised by
um consultes is actually a confirmation
to ensure that there wasn't actually
development on the triple SI it is
adjacent to it though and
the the issue really is around Richboro
generally is obviously you've got the
Richmond Towers historically and and all
that are around there is obviously
located directly next to designated
sites and
um obviously the council has previously
had to deal with nsip projects including
a lot of cables coming in through the
nature reserve and uh you know and it is
it's clearly this is a growth sector and
this isn't an issue that's going to be
the only time you're going to hear about
it as members in some part in terms of
what happens at Richboro
um and therefore he's always going to be
that balance indeed between trying to
protect the environment as much as
possible but acknowledging the fact that
this is an area that
is going to create these sorts of
Demands because of where it is on the
grid
noise which when when an area is quiet
noise can carry an extremely long
distance obviously disturbing humans and
any Wildlife so and also batteries I'm
not a physicist I've failed physics at
school will will there be some sort of
electromagnetic I'm not sure I'm using
the right technology you know pylons
give off uh electric they've got an
electric field where these batteries
have an electric field and is there any
is that detrimental to the wildlife
that's living in the area so so
basically I've got the noise of the fans
the possible potential noise of the fans
and obviously the the potential electric
field that could exist
in
I believe changed our role we've changed
our physics but that hasn't stayed with
me I'm afraid um the um so the
um I'm afraid I can't answer with
regards to the I suppose that we are a
lot I'm as the local plan Authority we
are relying on a combination of Natural
England the environment agency and KCC
biodiversity to look at the issues in
terms of the impact of this type of
facility the development has been
screened as to whether or not his
environmental impact assessment as well
um and it's not considered that that it
does
um to just pick up a couple of points
regards to the noise
um
the big concern actually in terms of the
noise is the noise of construction and
that's why there is a particular
requirement for details of how they're
going to mitigate the impact on its
Birds primarily and again it's it's
there are lots of gramping conditions on
this proposal because of that because
there's lots of stuff that's going to
need to come in and it's going to need
to be checked by KCC uh biodiversity
um there there is as mentioned
um the detail um
ecological mitigation habitat creation
plan talks about species and it also
talks about mitigation so um the points
to do with whether or not the actual
development when it's operational the
operational impacts we would consider
could be covered through that particular
condition to ensure that if there is any
need for anything because of any
potential impact it can be covered
through again the direct contact with
the consulties of of KCC biodiversity
I'm afraid I can't I can't speak to the
other elements of things I'm yeah I
struggle with that
uh thank you Ian Council Robin
yes thank you chair
um I'll take on both of my two
colleagues here have said in relation to
the
the greater issues of the wildlife Etc
um I I do think that we need to take
into account a major thing to take into
account is your location next to the
access to the main grid which is right
there
um
and uh Mr Livingston has used the word
balance and I think that's the right
word that we need to balance this out
and thinking for the future
the locations right in relation to the
grid
Etc the the experts in relation to the
wildlife and and everything that that
have given there
I wouldn't say blessing but they'd given
a nod of acceptance to it
um so
um our money to
vote for approval on his chair thank you
uh thank you I think of it Council
bayford
teacher yes as councilor Roberts said it
is about balance
um I feel everybody is aware that
storage of renewable energies is vital
to our future
no site is going to be perfect but
there are many Advantage here
particularly proximity to the grid it is
about balance and mitigation has been
put in place so on balance I feel that
we must support this application
I think accounts pay for Council Everett
yeah nobody's talked about the wind
turbine I've always been fascinated by
the winter but I understand it doesn't
work and hasn't worked for many many
years
um so whilst I assume that they don't
require planning permission to remove a
wind turbine
um there is a consequence of this
planning application and I think we
should welcome back because if we're
talking about the height of the uh the
battery units the wind turbine is
enormous and is visible highly visible
so if that's going that must be a good
thing
and also support the application thank
you Council Eric Council Cranston
I'm mindful to support the application
um I counselor Wing beat me to several
of the comments that I was concerned
about
um I just wanted to to double check
um from the reports and everything else
are we confident that the the height by
which this battery storage will be
raised will be sufficient and I was also
going to say about the longevity of the
of the the intended plan so for however
long this is expected to last which
you've already said we we don't know but
it's how confident are we that the three
meters is going to be adequate to
prevent damage from flooding
uh thank you
because yes I'll in come back here
um so
I suppose there are two elements of of
the of the flooding aspect
um one is the
um what the environment agency looked at
which is the the land level Point
um I will just I'll find their comment
and just see if I can review in terms of
um the the event that's been assessed in
the flood risk assessment at
um that subsequently been submitted
um there is also surface water drainage
which is obviously something that that
needs to be taken together is a
condition which would require details of
that because they are proposing to use
um effectively
um you know an outlet for that I'm just
going to quickly go to the uh
environment agency comments so it was
based on the the flood risk assessment
when the EA look at this sort of
development they are on looking on the
basis of it usually being permanent
um and
um they would normally flag up if they
thought it was some a development that
would affect
um
I suppose in this sort of 100 years type
situation
um you know so that that is the general
gist obviously the storm events that
could have happened obviously
we cannot foresee what storm events May
exceed in certain instances but this is
I suppose the the a
considered to be a reasonable option in
terms of increasing to the level that's
being proposed
you know it's
um
again it's a it's a reflection of the
area as well obviously this affects the
rich precise as well and obviously
that's been historically developed for
quite some time in terms of where it is
on style but again it's a balance here
and we consider that the If they raise
it to three meters it's acceptable to a
chord with what's in the flood risk
assessment specifically
thank you councilor Hart
thank you I must admit I think this is a
a sensible plan the only thing I can't
understand is why they haven't put solar
panels on top and generate some energy
while they've got all these units there
because if you put a panel on top of a
box it calls it down so you don't need
the fan so much and it would also run
the fans so it's just my comment really
it just seems a bit logical to have
battery storage without something that
can be actually useful and generate
power at the same time but am I just
being a knife as usual
yes
not at all Council Hart but I'm sure the
experts will come back on that counselor
wing
sorry I just gotta get labels I'll write
it on my head I do I just wanted to come
back on the surface water so up is the
surface water going into the the the
main drainage system is is it or is it
going straight into the stower OR into
the sea uh and if there is a a I mean
batteries are full of some hideous
chemicals we know that if is there a
contingency plan for the site if it
actually floods and we've got an
increased situation of storm storm
events that's fact so and you're looking
at 100 Year lifetime thank God I won't
be here but at some point it's likely
that that site will flood maybe not in
my lifetime but it will at some point
Pete
bear with us cancel me
I think we may have an answer ish
so the um
because I'm using my computer to to look
at this I can't I can't quickly just
check the flood risk assessment a
drainage strategy so I might have to
come back to you on a couple of those
points
um the common of KCC
um flood and water
um
effectively I I think we have a should
we have a short adjournment so I can
find out the information is that all
right sorry because I need to stop
presenting to find out the precise
details of the surface water drone if
that's just five minutes to
if that's in order members and members
of the public
that's unusual for this to happen so
thank you members
break is over
I think he members of the public for
your patience
um I think we've got a bit of an answer
here for you then
okay so thank you for that members and
um I'm afraid be prepared for me to
correct what I've said before
um so
um when I referred to the the Hundred
Years
um that related to effectively a 100
Year storm event
um rather than in terms of the the test
so that's specifically in relation to
um
the the potential for flooding
um in terms of the flood risk assessment
what that identifies is that part of the
site is in zone one of vast majorities
in zone one on the western end which is
the low risk of flooding but there are
bits that are in two and three
to your point earlier and not
identifying any other document the
lifespan of this development is 30 years
if they were modeling on a um
on a 0.5 chance of an annual exceedance
event so you know
a flood basically
um
there would be a potential issue in the
year 2070 in some areas of the site
above that three meter Ordnance datum
level
because the lifespan is put to be
effectively at until
um 2052
that's why the level has been set at
three meters in terms of basically means
that that would accommodate for a one at
0.5 percent annual chance of an annual
Seasons event and definitely covers the
vast majority of the site which is Zone
one which is effectively there's a
problem when it's a there's a 0.1 chance
of an annual season spent in those those
areas surface water drainage is a bit
bit trickier it does indicate in the
drainage strategy that's in the flood
risk assessment that there will be some
run after the star
it does outline the use of permeable
material a home materials where possible
and it does it include a drainage plan
which shows filter drains throughout the
whole development
which connects to an existing outfall
it indicates that the filter drones will
have capacity to avoid a effectively
flooding in a one in a hundred year
event if it really really rains that it
wouldn't actually cause flooding on the
site because of that the condition is
specifically put on to get the details
that KCC is the locally flood Authority
will look at in terms of where it
connects into the drainage Network
because it looks like from the the
images that we've seen that it connects
into the rest of the Richmond site
basically is where they'd look to to
connect in
so I hope that gives some clarity
apologies for the the errors earlier
thank you
uh thanks very much for that Ian um okay
I can't see any other speakers so I will
put this to you members
um uh the motion is for approval can
those
in favor please show hands please
those against
abstentions
one abstention that has been carried
thank you for that members thank you
the unit code for
clarified clarifying those bits there
a gender item for e is a 54 Stone Road
in broadstairs
this for approval but speaking as a
rejector to this application we have a
Mr Robin Curtis Mr Curtis are you with
us still you are right you have three
minutes please thank you Mr chair good
evening members I speak on behalf of
those residents of Stone Road who are
objecting to the construction of a new
four-bedroom detached house at number 54
Stone Road
we call this a new dwelling because let
us be clear what is being retained of
the present building in the proposed
development appears to be less than 25
percent of the original structure and
equates to no more than 10 percent of
the proposed residents it would
therefore seem a misnomer to call this
an extension
it is to all intents and purposes a new
build
it's worth pointing out that had the
planning application be more widely
promulgated there might well have been
more objections none of the customer
yellow planning application site notices
have been displayed we do not understand
why there is currently for instance one
on display on lampposts about 250 meters
along the road referring to a much less
significant extension
and I for example who live opposite
number 56a Stone Road and that's almost
directly opposite number 54 received no
formal notification of the application
we object on the following grounds one
loss of privacy and light to the
residents of Number 52a the proposed
first floor balcony as shown in the rear
east facing elevation will allow their
rear garden and Patio areas to be
overlooked with consequent loss of
privacy two the erection of this
two-story building are shown inside
south facing elevation will hugely
impact on the amount of light on the
north-facing wall and side passageway of
their property
to the application represents over
development which is out of keeping with
the area
successful the application would mean
that an area only recently occupied by
one detached four-bedroomed house and a
three-bedroom Bungalow would be occupied
by three four-bedroom detached houses
three inadequate parking provision
number 54 is situated on a bend in the
busy 205-2 in close proximity to a bus
stop
parking is already difficult at this in
Stone Road as may be seen from photos
forwarded to the planning officer if
members of the committee have not seen
these I have a copy here
the proposed development is very likely
to increase the number of cars based in
and accessing the proposed property but
no provision is made in the application
for an increased parking indeed the
intended extension of the front of the
property will actually decrease the
amount of parking space available
for loss of immunity The Proposal would
involve the further loss of a bungalow
in an area where Bungalows are at a
premium
we do hope that the planning committee
recognize our concern and also give full
weights to the concerns expressed
regarding this application by the
broadstairs society and the fact that
the Town Council have unanimously
recommended refusal We join with them in
requesting that in the unlikely event
that the application is improved
planning conditions should include the
retention of the existing Flint wall the
reinstatement of the previously
demolished print wall and that
Landscaping shown in plan zero four
should be planted if not already in
place thank you
uh thank you very much uh did you gather
I let you go over time which uh thank
you for the information uh right um Mr
Livingston again we'll outline this
application
thank you chair the
application is located in broadstairs so
this is a slightly wider view of Stone
Road so North at the top of the screen
South at the bottom
um with the c on the right hand side of
the image the property in question which
we'll zoom in on in a second is in the
center of the image where the mouse
pointer is is circling
uh this is the red line off the site so
it's number 54 so it's next to
56a which is a new build relatively new
build property uh and number 52 a uh on
the south side
so going in
um in a bit more detail
um the existing dwelling is here so it's
a chalet bungalow so you can see that
the roof forms of the neighboring
properties and the road itself with some
see some Vehicles parked there
so this is the Bungalow itself
um so the main issues for the proposal
which is um to extend this property with
a two-story uh series of extensions with
rear Terraces and alterations to the
external materials is the impact on the
character appearance the area impact on
the living conditions of neighboring
properties and Highway Safety so you can
see here that there's a there's a change
in level as you move through the site
from the road as you as it sort of site
Falls away towards the towards the sea
and we'll see that with images that show
properties on either side of the road in
a bit you can see the Flint wall that's
been mentioned as well
so looking to the the right you have a
52a
which is a two-story property with a
pitched roof and then looking to the
left you've got
um
you've got 56a that was the new build
property that's been mentioned
this is this is a Google Street View
image
um which just shows that change in
levels so you've got the properties that
are
two-story but with quite large pitch
roofs opposite and a sort of mix of
properties includes shallow Bungalows
two-story detached properties a variety
of different designs on one side of the
road as well and then you can see the
change in level that occurs with the
properties on the right hand side of the
image
so this is a view of the rear elevation
of the existing Chalet bungalow
so looking to the right so that's the
back of of 56a since it's three story at
the back two stories at the front and
then the back of 52a as well so just
showing the the sort of nearest
rear-facing habitable in Windows
so this is the existing uh block plan of
uh The Bungalow this is the proposed
block plan uh just showing it here
members just to give you the context of
the existing and then the proposed so it
changes I suppose the location of of the
mass of the dwelling for being two-story
the footprint is increasing as part of
this scheme
so just going through the existing plans
so the Chalet Bungalow at the moment
shows three bedrooms on the ground floor
um you've then got the the roof form
that we've already seen
and just going through the elevation so
you've got the front elevation
and the rear elevation that we've seen
in terms of the side elevations you can
see there are at the moment there are
side windows that serve that property at
the ground floor level and again this
just shows that change in levels across
the site as well
and this is the other side view
um so on the top you've got the existing
Street Scene showing the heights of
adjacent properties in relation to the
Chalet Bungalow and then you've got at
the bottom you've got a street scene
that shows the proposal so with the
black dotted line showing the form of
the existing roof so the the design
changes to create a Gable end on the
front you have um render within that
that Gable and then brick slips on the
right hand side with a pitch Groove
pitching back on the right hand side uh
map linking into that Gable end roof so
the um the eaves height
um is is less than the neighboring
property but matches the newer property
at number 56a on the left hand side of
the image with a Gable design which is
similar to the properties on sort of to
the north of this dwelling
so just looking at the full plans of the
proposed
um this is the ground floor plan if I
can direct members attention to the
Terrace at the rear
um you can see here there's an
annotation which states uh a 1.8 meter
high obscure glaze screen to be
installed next to the Terrace there and
that's uh to protect the amenities of uh
the neighbor at 52 a
um in terms of the upper sorry the first
floor plan you've got a four bedroom
property from the three bed at the
moment you've also got a balcony at the
rear obviously facing towards the sea
um what's important about this balcony
those is inset so you can see that the
walls either side actually go past the
balcony doesn't protrude out which means
you can't look side to side directly
down into the neighboring properties
you're directed in terms of view out
towards the rear of the garden
so as mentioned this is a change in
materials of the property so white
render with brick slips around the the
feature with um with cladding as well
um you've got
um obviously a mix in the area we've
seen from the photos that there are
examples of render those examples of
brick um there is a condition that we're
recommending in terms of making sure we
get the samples of the materials because
obviously this is a property that's got
both render and brick and obviously
they're different brick colors that are
in the area trying to ensure that it
matches as close as possible to the the
vernacular materials that are there and
that it is reflective of the streets in
terms of the rear elevation so on the
left hand side as mentioned you've got
the 1.8 meter high obscure screen from
the level of the Terrace to avoid an
impact on the neighboring property
and then you can see that's the inset
balcony here
the side elevations you've got an
obscure glazed window which serves the
the hallway
um with some ground floor windows again
there's a reduction in the side windows
from the previous scheme
and then on the other side it's a buying
calibration so this is the elevation
that is adjacent to the neighbor that
protrudes further into the site which is
number
56a so if we go to the the block plan
um
in terms of impact on neighboring
properties
um the the dwelling doesn't
um doesn't protrude past the habitable
room windows
um significantly for number 52a because
of both the gap between the two
properties that you can see on the image
as well as the fact that it's staggered
at the back in terms of the impact from
on number 56a that property already
extends further back into the site and
therefore it's considered that they
wouldn't be harm to either property
either side in terms of impact on
primary Outlook as well as that it's
considered that the dwelling wouldn't
appear cramped in its setting because of
the
um the the separation distance from the
boundaries you have a single story
element to match the single story
element that's there at the moment on
the left hand side of the property
um which is obviously next to where
you've got the drive for number 56a that
does extend further back than the
existing single story element on the
property so it extends back into the
site but we don't consider that would
cause a harmful visual impact on the
area
um in terms of concerns to do with uh
parking So currently the property
benefits from off street parking
um and there is no proposal to change
the existing access to be used you've
got two off Street spaces at the moment
um obviously it does increase this
property by a bedroom
um there is
um some images that have been put into
the the box in the members room that's
been circulated
um raising concerns about congestion at
different times obviously predominantly
this the summer for obvious reasons
regards the location and the fact that
you've got the properties to the west of
the road don't have parking off off
Street and so they would park on the
road
um however in terms of we're moving from
three bedrooms to four and obviously
even if that generates an additional
vehicle which it doesn't necessarily and
obviously it's very family dependent
you've obviously got two off-street
spaces already and one car added to
Stone Road code isn't considered to be a
material impact to Warrant refusal of
the application in terms of a severe
harm to highway safety an extension to a
property doesn't even warrant a highway
Authority even giving us a comment
because of the level of or the lack of
impact that I would normally have on the
network so it's not considered that
they're not proposing to change the
access there's no impact on visibility
supplies and they're obviously still
retaining the parking that's available
and that can is considered to be
sufficient concern has been raised about
the the loss of the front boundary wall
um the agent stated it's it is to be
retained there is a a suggested
condition that the officers recommended
um would could be put forward I do think
it's important to note though that
there is a question
um about whether or not
um the demolition of the wall we're
looking at a wall that's one meter in
height it's not a Conservation Area
whether or not that wall could
technically be demolished as not even
constituting development under the
planning act which is an issue that has
come up in various issues in the local
area including even in conservation
areas as well
obviously the intention though from the
applicant is stated to be retained I
know it's a very important point that
that's come up with and it came up with
the development adjacent where the Flint
Wall came down and that raised a number
of concerns but obviously the agent is
stating that they're looking to retain
it and we obviously would like them to
retain it but obviously if it does
constitute something that just doesn't
actually require planning permission the
power that we have is limited here but
they are obviously proposing to retain
it
so in terms of overall
it is considered that the design is
appropriate um in terms of the scale and
mass of what's being proposed given the
neighboring properties there you have
large detached properties the nature of
it being two stories and considered to
be out of character because of the fact
that it's set in and the requirements
have been put in place with regards to a
privacy screen Etc an obscure glazing on
side windows it's not considered to
impact on neighboring properties and
therefore it is it is recommended for
approval thank you chair uh thank you
and I moved the officer's recommendation
as you heard is for approval because the
vice chair please second oh second
nature thank you Council Coleman cook
members
think about space
you know this is a
huge extension
um and it does change the street scene
however
clearly there is going to be development
further development on this site
and it does seem that
lengths have been taken to
for this property to blend in within the
properties around
in terms of materials the inset balcony
and the privacy screen
I can understand the concerns of
residents because it does change the
street scene but
in view of the fact that development is
going to take place anyway
I think
perhaps this is the this is much much
more acceptable than the previous
application
and I think maybe the best we're going
to get so I think probably should let
this go through thank you thank you
councilor Beaufort councilwin yes thanks
chair
um
I agree with uh the gentleman there
who's who said this is basically a new
bill
it basically is I don't think we can get
away from that point
however
I think we've got to look at what is
either side of this building of this
Bungalow The Bungalow is a minuscule in
comparison to what's to what is either
side
and I think the design is good I think
it fits in with a street scene myself
and uh so that's all I want to say thank
you chair thank you councilor over and
catch your shrub
s
both sides I feel that putting that a
new build as it could be seen as
um
on new finish now but you didn't ping
your microphone
you didn't put your microphone on don't
worry
oh sorry but I was just gonna say it
looks both sides were over
um overlooked
um so I feel that this would just be
within keeping with
the street scene myself and I will
approve this
account councilor Clinton yeah actually
having my hand up councilor Schwab has
said very similar to what I was going to
say this is the one that looks the odd
one out at the moment and
yes it is a massive change and a
complete almost new development but uh I
think it will be an improvement on the
street scene it will be more in keeping
with what's already there either side
thank you very much Council Ghana
yeah
um I I'm sorry come here a long time I
mean I I have serious concerns about
this
my my concern
is this quite clearly is over
development and it's over development in
an area that is being continually
overdeveloped and that you could be you
can tell by the numbering system that's
changed along this road there are so
many A's along there they're slot in
these
that the whole area has changed in its
Outlook this Bungalow wouldn't have been
out of place not that long ago and it's
a shame
it's a shame that we keep
seeing these in a piecemeal one at a
time application as as I guess we have
to and we don't look at the bigger
picture as to what we're turning
this area and a number of other areas
into
um
one thing that was mentioned in the
report as well and I have
as Ian knows I have concerns about the
loss of Flint wolves in there these are
these are Heritage features of the town
and
because they are of a certain height it
seems people are allowed to just knock
them down willy-nilly I mean I was
pleased earlier on at the first
application that
um attention was paid to the Flint
wolves in that in that building and we
did make sure that those Flint walls
were kept but the way they're going in
broadstairs at the moments and Peters we
seem to be losing all of the Flint walls
and I'm
also concerned that
this is uh this is a concern that has
been addressed by the Town Council in
broadstairs and they've heard plan in
boardstairs has a policy in it about the
retention of these Heritage features
which seemed to be just overlooked
um I think the Town Council did go to a
lot of effort and time and effort to
produce a plan to enable these features
of our town to be kept and it's being
overlooked and I'm very
Disturbed I think that this just keeps
happening time and time again so yeah I
mean I would be interested to hear Ian
to come back and and answer that
um
so
as I've just sum up by saying as we
if we keep looking at these applications
one after another without without
thinking about the medium to long term
about about our town and through from
what it looks to me paying little
attention to the town's neighborhood
plan then we're just going to be going
from from bad to worse thank you I think
it has gone I'm gonna bring back Mr
Livingston
uh oh yeah just to come back on the the
front wall point out indeed the
neighborhood plan obviously identifies a
number of issues to do with Heritage
features which would obviously want to
be retained where possible obviously
this proposal isn't actually stating
they're going to demolish the Flint wall
um it's I suppose the the concern that's
being raised is is the risk that it
happens as happened next door uh which
is what happened in this instance
um
it is a tricky situation because we're
governed by the legislation on a
national basis in terms of actually it's
not it's not even that it's a question
of what's permitted development it's
actually that it doesn't even constitute
development at all under the ACT which
is the issue as to whether or not it
constitutes relevant Demolition and
we're not in a conservation area which
is when if you start to do things in
Conservation Area then you're bound by
Heights in a different way
um
but again I suppose it comes back to
that point that it's not being proposed
to be removed um obviously we've raised
it with the applicant they're clearly
very aware of it and I'm sure there will
be a reaction and maybe an
understandable reaction if it was to be
taken down
um and so I I you know we we've
obviously put forward what we've put
forward but obviously there's the
applicant's intention is is clearly
something that is for their their own
decision about it
uh thank you in concert bayford come
back
thank you chair
um
I I accept the things that councilor
gone has said and I'm also very
respectful of
um balls Desmond and Saint Peter's Town
councils
um
uh Naval plan
however planning legislation has changed
which we all know
and many many areas are changing
and I think it's important that we look
for the best possible changes that we
can find
um
this
this development does seem to have tried
seemed to have
tried to fit in with the with the street
seeing as best possible
in terms of materials and I say the
inset balcony the privacy screens
I think
although
change is not desirable I think it's
probably
unacceptable change and feel that
residents probably will find that it is
not
detrimental to their living in the
future so I feel probably we should go
with this one thank you uh thank you
council's favorite Council wing
given my own recent experience uh
personal experience in terms of planning
I just this is a massive development in
terms of its height and its and its
physi both both vertically and
horizontally to gain an additional
bedroom which I find
I find overbearing it encroaches he's
going to take the light uh you know I
won't be supporting this because I I
would gain one more bedroom and we're
encroaching on that side with that
property there we're going up so we're
overlooking uh no it's it's it's too
much I don't understand the the the the
the I don't understand the theory behind
wanting to build something massively
bigger to just have one more additional
bedroom and lose your garage as well
I think applicants have the right to put
in these applications Council a wing and
totally understand your comment on your
personal one no counselor Everett
yeah and so I respect the fact that um
people are nervous about changing their
environment and and what impact they
might have on their living conditions
but I have to say
um looking at it from the evidence
that's been presented to us that is an
improvement to the straight scene I
don't think it's over development and
again there's no point whatsoever
turning down applications which we know
very well will go through on appeal
um from a planning inspector if they're
appealed and we just we just Pander to
um you know we're just playing games
with residents if we if we if we reject
applications which we know will go
through on appeal and this one would
certainly go through an appeal and it
should be passed tonight and I'll be
voting for it
uh thank you for that cancer over it to
write so call the hall yeah I don't
think there's anybody else to speak so
members put this to you
um you should obviously the officer's
recommendation is for approval those in
favor
those against
once again that has been carried thank
you members
all right uh moving on now to agenda
item for G
uh which is Joss Gap Road broadstairs
speaking in favor of the application is
a Mr Christian
letter if I've got it right Paul Terror
I beg your pardon thank you chair
um I'm representing the majority of 31
freeholders at Kingsley Castle
while supporting the proposals in
principle we have a number of concerns
since 2014 and 2015 until now we
believed that we had reached a
compromised agreement in going forward
in developing a footpath over the
private land which incidentally isn't a
Conservation Area
and we own this and it's called the
triangle having met Kate Beswick from
Kent County Council for the first time
and Jenny Bowen Natural England in April
and June this year we were able to catch
up on all the meetings we had take that
had taken place since 2015.
we felt encouraged that comments made by
John eldidge acting for us raised
concerns on a number of issues that
would help to make sure that a pathway
is constructed that is safe for
pedestrians and durable
a copy of my email to duncanfit has been
emailed to you all I believe enabling
you to understand our concerns including
an attachment that raises those
particular points
I'd like to refer you to a number of key
concerns that need clarification
black metal railing to be in the style
that is in keeping with the entrance
gate of Kingsley Castle was agreed and
should be adopted
and Mr Livingston very kindly gave me
the answer that we wanted which is the
height of the railing which is one meter
not the two meters of the fence that
goes alongside the
um
the golf course
we have seen the increase in traffic
over the summer months resulting in
illegal parking over double yellow lines
and the existing footpath from Kings 8
bay to the castle entrance
to have a safe and durable footpath and
avoid conflict between pedestrians and
vehicles on the site we must protect
this by preventing cars parking on the
footpath which is why we believe
strongly in having bollards in the style
shown in our proposals
the report acknowledges some modest
alterations to land levels may be
required to create a level service along
the path
it is nevertheless important for the
area behind the railings which is
between 0.5 meters and 0.6 meters above
the level of the proposed footpath
steps should be taken to address this
difference in levels otherwise the soil
behind the left railings will inevitably
wash down onto the footpath
in the light of our concerns we'd very
much like to invite you all to visit the
site and assess these issues yourselves
and therefore defer the application
thank you for your time uh thank you
very much uh speaking as a chapter at
this application is a miss Karen
McKenzie
Mackenzie you have three minutes
thank you chair and committee I'm the
voluntary tree warden for broadstairs
and St Peters but my concerns are
broader than trees perhaps KCC couldn't
care less about the dangerous parking
situation or the speeding traffic along
this narrow stretch of road these
problems should surely be solved before
the expense of this footpath scheme for
the national Coastal path
my objections on the portal explain all
the policies that are in conflict with
this application there are too many for
three minutes
my following points are in addition
Kingsgate Castle residents own the
triangle of land at the North End and
any work should be with their consent
and their questions have remained
unanswered this is unacceptable
outline planning permission was granted
in 2018 and the process is running
roughshod over local residents and
landowners concerns foreign
this is an insult to yourselves and your
office as representatives of the
residents of thanet so moving on to
reasons why you should refuse this
application and ask KCC to think again
here are a few more
Walkers already using a route past the
green and the two T's on the golf course
instead of the road they join the paved
area through the triangle quite safely
was this route ever considered and if
not why not
this route would mean less environmental
destruction and a lot less cost
a rubber grow through surface on the
path could make it accessible for
wheelchair users the golf club could
move the teas Westward to allow more
room for a footpath here
path users could manage their own safety
when Crossing many golf courses have a
bell installed for this purpose for
alerting golfers to Crossing pedestrians
fencing is to be erected for safety from
errant golf balls some stats for you out
of 946
000 golf players in the UK there are
just three and a half thousand golf ball
injuries so the risk of getting hit by a
golf ball if you are a player is less
than one percent and significantly less
therefore if you occasionally cross the
back of a green and ring a bell
KCC environment officer States a bat
emergence survey should be conducted but
it hasn't and you can't do one now until
next May because bats are hibernating
replacement planting for the Lost trees
and shrubs in appendix B lacks detail
one page of minuscule print who will be
responsible for maintaining and
replacing the shrubs and saplings in the
Triangle belonging to Residents if they
fail to thrive who pays who maintains
these
so to conclude it seems that the
concerns of you and your electorate and
even a KCC staffer are of no concern at
all to the project team I wonder them
why we are here perhaps you do have some
power please refuse this application and
ask them to defer let's get some decent
consultation going we need acceptable
Solutions and answers not a Stonewall
thank you
uh thank you very much right and ask Mrs
Livingston I believe
for his report thank you
thank you chair
um so the application site runs along
from Convent road down part of uh just
Gap roads you've got the properties as
mentioned so you've got Kingsgate castle
at the top here various housing
developments that come forward uh over
the last 30 years
going in a little bit more detail this
is the red line so you're you're seeing
the the part of the the area that's to
be partially cleared for the footpath
running along down just get Road
um
to give you some context
the the triangle that's been mentioned
um obviously as mentioned owned by uh
can you say castle residence is in the
conservation area so the translucent
blue is the conservation area the vast
majority of the the red line because the
site is not in the Conservation Area
um so this is
um C to the the top of the image so
we're slightly at once on one side so
you've got the triangle at Cumberland
Road here
um and then the site itself running
along you can see where see the the t's
mentioned that the golf course there and
then what you can see at the end here is
the existing footpath which The Proposal
is to connect into so this stretch of
road here doesn't have any footpath and
I'm sure most people are probably
familiar with this but we will show some
some images as well
so just to show the red line on some of
those satellite images so this is the
left hand side or the northern part of
the where the red line goes
and then it goes through the site and
then it joins up with that footpath
there
so to actually look at the proposal
itself
um
what you have is a variety of works all
the way along the proposed route so the
actual footpath itself that be created
is a compacted Limestone surface you've
got if we're looking at the conservation
area part you have a railing that's
proposed along to along and when you're
directly adjacent to the footpath here
so it's where this arrow is is noting so
there's the uh things saying proposed
railing so just to confirm again that's
a black railing as confirmed in the
planning statement it's one meter in
height
um and uh what's brewing Pros there is
some vegetations being cut back to
expose basically the area of the moment
that's that's there and then the
footpath itself starts here
and extends along it then extends round
and goes away from the road slightly to
go around the trees that are that are
there you then it changes from a railing
to a two meter high screen it's a fence
which is being erected and that's
erected in the center you can see the
red line in the center of that or sorry
bisecting that green area so the green
area is the planting area and we'll show
you what that looks like as well so
there's specific planting that's being
proposed along this route
and then moving through so that whole
green area is where additional planting
is to take place so the footpath itself
is is 1.5 meters wide so this isn't a
cycle way as well because the width
would be much greater than the 1.5 so
that's why at the end you have uh cycle
chicanes that have been being proposed
so cyclists would have to come off and
on to just Gap Road to go up
um you then obviously it joins back into
here so this is the two meter height
fence that runs alongside there so look
at what that looks like uh from the road
this is on the corner of where the the
bench is it in the Triangle bit of the
site
um so the footpath itself sort of Peters
off as you can see here as you go down
uh just got road so that would continue
along the frontage all the way to
this point here where you've got the
access in and if I just skip back
quickly you can see this is that access
in the center there so then it would
continue along
a bit more so it would remove this
growth here and then it would cut inside
and this is a view from the other end so
here is the end of the axis so then all
the way along then you're running behind
the planting that's the front there to
be retained the the screen that you've
got there at the moment you can see
again the the width of that road you've
got a bit of a pedestrian root on the
Eastern side of just Gap Road
but then it is you know no pedestrian
access and it's as you can see the
double yellow lines all the way along
that stretch as well
so the main considerations for this are
outlined in the report so we are in the
countryside we're also in the green
wedge
um the officer report goes through those
considerations and does consider it that
the proposal would align with part of
the green wedge policy
um in terms of the balance here it's
fundamentally about the balance between
the loss of um of certain bits of
habitat this is a local Wildlife site
again so again the policy gio2 requires
there to be mitigation put in place when
any of any of that is to be lost
um it's about balancing the improvements
to highway safety which would occur we
do consider there is a benefit here from
obviously providing a footpath that
simply isn't there mention has been made
about the project itself it's a it's a
joint it's a natural England project
that's jointly being put for by KCC as
part of the coastal path project
um
obviously planning permission here is
required
for the physical works that are
occurring what it is important to note
though is that
there are trees that are being lost
within the conservation area so there
are two particular trees that are the
orange trees so not the blue blue root
protection areas that are being
protected as part of this application
but there are two category sea trees
that have been removed and there are
trees that are being removed in actually
where the red area is which is showing
where the clearance is going to occur
further down now those red areas when
you're not in the conservation area
there is no protection on the the trees
that are there or the the scrub growth
itself that could be removed without
permission but obviously it is
acknowledged that as the proposal has
come in we have to consider the policy
framework and therefore the local
Wildlife site does need to be considered
um
in terms of the issues that have been
raised
um one of the issues has been raised is
the change in land levels and there is a
I think actually if I go back to
might be able to see in this image
actually there is a there is a change in
land levels across the two but it's the
site
um officers haven't felt it necessary to
put a levels condition on in this
instance because it's not considered
there is necessarily any automatic harm
that would be created that we need to
either mitigate or check by virtue of
the footpath obviously the footpath is
is to be designed to be as obviously as
flat as possible because obviously to
try and improve access and KCC public
rights away are the people that are
actually going to be implementing this
project effectively or controlling this
project and therefore we are confident
in in their ability to do that without
necessarily having to get a level survey
members felt that to be necessary that
is a condition that could be added to
the the recommendation for approval
officers though haven't haven't put it
on
um there was quite a bit back and forth
with regards to ecology itself
um because of the fact of obviously the
removal that's occurring
um in particular
um KCC biodiversity have looked at the
actual mitigation planting that's to
occur so
um
if you're looking at the top image there
on the left hand side is is the line of
the fence line you can see then the
cross section and the bottom image there
in terms of that two meter High
um that two meter high fence so what
you've got in that area that that green
area if we go back to the image there we
go in the green area we have
um a planting schedule that's been
submitted which includes a mixture of
native tree species to be planted as
well as climbers for the actual proposed
fence itself of Honeysuckle and Irish
Ivy at two meter intervals all the way
along there
um it does indicate that they are going
to infill gaps where possible we
obviously have this the plan which is
go back to it sorry which is this plan
which identifies the methodology as well
and this would be conditioned as part of
the the proposal to come forward again
that has been looked at by
um the separate element of KCC who are
quite rigorous with their colleagues
about what they needed to provide and as
mentioned the bat survey so this is an
issue in terms of actually to do with
the works to the trees it's not so much
the physical works of the ground it's
actually The Works of the trees itself
and there is a condition that's looking
to safeguard that any tree Works
couldn't occur until the survey has been
done obviously mentions have been made
of the time limit that would be
necessary
that is a time limit that would then
have to be adhered to because the survey
has come in and be signed off so it may
mean that some Works can occur but the
point in in line with the wildlife and
Countryside Act is ensuring that there
aren't any isn't any impact from any
Works to uh trees there that could
affect protected species and therefore
both with the protection of the
legislation but also with the condition
we consider this to be sufficient
so
again it's a word that that I used
earlier this is a this is a balance
fundamentally you're looking at work
that is occurring in the green wage in
the countryside but there is a tangible
benefit uh in terms of the the benefit
that it provides in terms of pedestrians
and safeguarding in terms of concern
sorry at one point I I didn't mention
um in terms of the highway safety
concerns there is some concern that's
been raised with the um the Gap that you
have in some places between the footpath
and the road itself and you can see it
in this cross section on the top image
there and the bottom image as well about
that 500 mil and that it could encourage
people to park in that area
there are double yellow lines along
there now I appreciate residents I'm
sure are quite used to people parking
along there and uh there being an issue
with that fundamentally the design
itself doesn't automatically wouldn't
automatically lead to this type of
parking occurring and there are controls
in place
um and I don't want to shunt the blame
onto other departments at either the
council or KCC but it is a matter for
Park enforcement about those parking
laws being adhered to
um in in terms of looking at that
overall
um again it is a balance we do think
there is um there's a benefit to
pedestrian safety but it's acknowledged
that there is a need for mitigation
planting because of the impact that it
would have on the local Wildlife site
but it is recommended for approval thank
you chair uh thank you very much Ian Van
scale and I moved the officer's
recommendation which you understand is
for Approved with the vice chair please
second oh second nature I think Council
councilor Auburn
thank you chair
um
it just seems like a total distraction
of
the scenery that would learn the trees
the area I just
finished relatively small
footpath to be put in
it's not been necessary
for our Everlong I've been here since
the 1970s
and I'll play golf sometimes and I'll
play golf at northfall in there and um
and plus gone up down there many many
many times
and uh I I just don't see the actual
need for this I know what it says I've
read I've read the report in relation to
you know this is the Secretary of State
and we've got this new this foot path
for England football but
for what they want to put in and the
amount of Destruction that is going to
take place I I don't see it fits you I'm
sorry thank you thank you can say hi
thank you chair I do agree with Council
Auburn Believe It or Not which is quite
unusual isn't it um but I would like to
know because obviously this has been
thought of in a major construction way
how many people are going to use this
footpath has any estimation been put
forward as to is it a hundred people a
week is it 100 people a month it's 100
people a year
um so some sort of survey must have been
done on how many people walk down that
road otherwise
it wouldn't be deemed necessary so
um I'd like to know from uh
planning officers please how many people
they expect to use this part thank you
I'm afraid I don't have that information
um whether or not other
um I mean the project itself I think
it's the context of the project is it is
a nationwide project by Natural England
to try and create this Coastal path and
um obviously the the principle is
something that sort of has been
um mentioned again in terms of the
Secretary of State I think the
the reality is to get a pedestrian root
which I do think is supported
by a number of people
there is no other place you could put it
without effectively incur if you go on
the other side of the road it's private
Residential Properties it's just never
going to come forward on that basis the
issue is then that balance between
what the harm is from what's what's
occurring and obviously the the point
here is that the policy itself the local
Wildlife policy specifically cites that
it does allow for loss it's not say you
can't have an impact it's saying if it's
only if sufficient mitigation is in
place and that is why obviously with the
fact that the you know if this is
unmanaged area at the moment obviously
what's being proposed is planting of
native species which have been endorsed
in terms of the variety that's being
provided it is acknowledged though that
you will you will require certain areas
to be you know effectively you'll need
to make the footpath there so they will
be removing areas but the balance is
obviously the key bit that obviously I
defer to members in terms of that
uh thank you Council bayford
I would have been very very happy to
have had a footpath thing I found it
quite concerning
there's more far more traffic now than
there was then and I feel that a
footpath is is necessary however
I think the Kingsgate Castle is a very
very beautiful building and it's a
landmark that's that seems far from far
and wide and I think the residents keep
their cars keep the grounds beautifully
and have sound knowledge about what fits
in and what doesn't
in which case I think that their views
should be taken into consideration
um the the issue of the railings has
been addressed they will be the black
color that's required I think that their
comments about land leveling should be
considered
I also wonder about the bollards
although that probably would be a KCC
issue but I feel we do need this
footpath I very much support it but I
I do think that the views that the
residents have put forward from the
castle should be taken into account
uh thank you Council Wallings yes
thank you Jay
um yeah I've got to say that as a few
years ago I had the great privilege of
spending just over eight months in
hospital after being hit by a car and
you know it was a different place I
fully support anything to make
pedestrians around the road safer so
totally supports it
thank you councilor Wright
just clarify do I as I understand it
that means the New Path would have trees
I I voltage either side of it
or would it be out on would it would so
part of part of it is is on the road so
it's the continuation would occur if I
go to this image so the footpath would
continue along here and then before if I
go back then what happens is so it's a
long it's along the road with the the
trees that are to be retained along here
then it it basically Cuts in so there
will be trees still on the road and the
football thing goes behind those trees
one thing that has been identified is
that the trees when the footpath is
within the root protection area they are
looking to effectively put
um hang on
wrong plan
so
when when there is work within tree root
protection areas a cell where
construction so basically there's
you effectively lay it on the existing
level so you're not actually Excavating
to put the footpath in yeah that wasn't
that that wasn't wasn't actually much
concerned my concern is that it's good
that it may be creating a quite a
vulnerable space for people walking on
their own if they're walking at night
and I'm just a little bit concerned
maybe it would be better if it was on
the outside so that it's visible from
the road just in case anybody was in
trouble
I mean in terms of The Proposal itself
it has obviously it's been put forward
um and the reason why I think it's to
divert away and go round as you can see
from the image of the sort of right hand
side is actually to try and avoid losing
more of the trees I think because
obviously you've got quite a lot of
right trees right on the road
um it's to try and avoid that again
obviously I appreciate the concerns may
be there in terms of safety it's not
proposed to to light this path
um but again it's not considered that it
creates a a safety concern that would
would necessarily warrant any need for
lighting but that's that's our view
admittedly
thank you Council Scranton
thank you
um I confess I have rather mixed
feelings about this
um on the one hand I do think that the
there is a benefit in increased
pedestrian safety and uh considering
that we want to promote cycling and
walking walking in particular
um I think we need to take that into
account
I do have a concern that maybe the
proposal to approve may have some
influence from who the uh
um planning application is being put
forward by in as much as this is Kent
County Council
um and I do I am concerned that we don't
seem to have listened enough to the
residents concerns which has been raised
um as well by others
so but those are my two issues
um and I'm wondering whether or not a
site visit might help clarify some of
those issues for the residents
um
don't do that
okay sit down just to walk down there at
the moment
um but uh thank you councilor Auburn
um
yeah those are my thoughts but thank you
uh I'm gonna bring Ian back in just I
mean I I get unsurprisingly I'm I the
the applicant the relevance of the
applicant I suppose is is only in so
much as obviously it is the this has
come forward from sort of public rights
of way team and obviously the principles
that they're putting forward it's more
about the merits of the case rather than
the applicant indeed we um continually
annoy KCC by not approving their housing
developments especially around the
Buffalo well the primary school in
cliftonville
um but yeah it's
um
yeah I'm sorry I don't think there's
probably anything else I can add to that
thank you um Council
thank you chair
um I drove down there twice did I on
both occasions there were a number of
people
um walking down that road which was
quite I thought quite sort of dodgy but
what I wonder is if they're walking down
there at night with no lights that's
going to be dangerous
so I'm fully support footpath and
anything that will protect people thank
you
thank you our councilor Ghana
thank you yeah well I'll I'll start by
saying
um
having a footpath isn't this isn't a bad
thing so counselor Wallin and common
cook
I agree they're a footpath here would be
helpful but this shouldn't be a binary
issue in that there isn't a footpath so
we have to have a footpath so we'll
agree whatever footpath is put in front
of us the footpath that is being
proposed is going to result in as
councilor Auburn has said the
removal of a large number of trees and
Hedgerow unnecessarily some of those
trees are in a conservation area and
some aren't I mean to me it does yeah
that only matters in terms of them
needing permission but the loss of any
of them is a is a bad thing and I do and
just some details about that two of
those trees are quite significant home
Oaks six meters and seven and a half
meters tall
and we do as an aside we do seem to be a
bit too Keen to give permission to um
fail home Oaks in the district
so I don't think the argument here is
necessarily whether or not a footpath is
a good thing it's whether it's the right
footpath there are
one thing I will say oh this is the
first
first time at planning committee I think
where
a member of the public speaking in
support
of the application has helped convince
me that I don't I don't I'm not minded
to support it because there are so many
issues still outstanding that don't seem
to have been resolved through
conversations or further conversations
with the residents who know who know
what they're talking about
um
and I think that that needs to be so an
option we should consider is as as was
suggested Barbers maybe a site visit and
obviously to get a site visit we need to
refuse permission just as a reminder to
everybody
um and there should be an opportunity to
look at other safe routes for this
footpath
um there are
further away from the road nearer the
golf course I would suggest that there
maybe should be
more consideration given to that
um and just one other thing I wanted to
mention you mentioned a pack that survey
needed doing
um as has been mentioned that that
survey can't be done until
the bats are up and about which is next
May so that gives time for more
consideration I would suggest for a
better route for the footpath rather
than the one that is causing so much
destruction next to the road
I'm going to bring back Ian once again
um thanks I mean the I can't I can't
speak to the sort of provenance of how
the precise route has been determined
um in terms of the level
um you know of disruption that this this
does cause obviously there's
the reality is that the golf course
obviously is is present but you can see
in these these images exactly how close
it goes to those areas it's unlikely to
get delivered if if there's any
potential to try and actually change
those areas obviously this is this is
the footpath to try and be as close to
the alignment of the existing footpath
as possible and
um and then therefore obviously that's
likely to have informed the route that
that has been taken I think just to pick
up the point with regards to the the
concerns that have been raised by
residents one of the issues that we
haven't discussed is the wish uh
effectively for I suppose more
mitigation planting around where the
railings are going so at the moment
you've got the railings that would be in
effectively in the image that's that's
there and obviously the planting area
that's proposed is the green area which
is around the fence
um
domestication hasn't been proposed
because obviously what is actually being
attempted to do is is just use the the
planting that's there and actually just
erect some quite small uh railings
obviously the reason why they're ratings
primarily is because it's in a
Conservation Area
um and that's why we've looked condition
the design
um the mitigation planting in that area
I suppose isn't considered necessary
um because there isn't actually as much
of an impact there as there is further
on down and especially there isn't
something that needs to be screened
which obviously in terms of the fence
then we agree it does need to be
screened to some extent by the planting
as well as actually providing some
native planting to compensate for the
loss that that occurs obviously we've
clarified a bit about the railings in
terms of the height and the color and
again in terms of the level survey if
members felt that that was a particular
need then it is something that could be
could be added but obviously that's one
of a number of points the members have
raised so
uh thank you Council print and come back
thank you
um coming back to the safety issues um
with cars um and uh really councilor
common Cook's comment made me want to
say this
um as a woman most likely to be walking
on my own if it was dark even at four
o'clock in the afternoon on a Winter's
day I guarantee I will not be on that
path because I will be out of sight and
very feeling very very vulnerable so I
think you know can we kind of bear that
in mind because that is actually a
safety element all these trees are very
nice but
um I'm going to be out on the road with
the cars where people can see me in
headlights if nothing else
um so and I think that's the point that
actually councilor um Wright was trying
to make as well just now so just
something to think about
um just on on that absolutely understand
perspective the one thing I'd say is
that there aren't street lights along
that road at the moment
um so in terms of the illumination of
the bit of the footpath that's not
actually got a foot way there is
obviously there's there is a especially
in the road so there's more Vehicles
potentially what you can see in this
image though is that the actual footpath
that is in place the other Road does run
all the way down just Gap Road so that
is an existing footpath obviously an
existing relationship but absolutely
understanding you as you say you
wouldn't walk along there anyway but but
that's why it's not again it's not
considered this
again it's it's difficult because it's a
personal choice about what people do or
not but again it's not a reason that we
would resist the development by virtue
of it definitely leading to a public
safety issue I'm now going to bring my
colleague in
um who probably doesn't know I'm going
to bring her in
um who's just mentioned that she was
actually involved in the initial
discussions about this which one was not
aware so
um yeah about a year ago um KCC
approached us and I had some initial
meetings with them talking about
different options and they had some
different options for the footpath that
they put to me and said oh these are the
different things we're looking at so the
advice I'd given them was to look at the
um location of the path that would
result in the loss of the least number
of trees so I encourage them to go out
and do a survey of the trees and work
out for you plotting where the trees
were on a plan where they could create a
path that would result in the least
number of trees being removed because
um protection of the tree is obviously
is quite important in terms of the
immunity of the area
um the concern they had because they
were talking they were trying to talk to
the golf course as well and obviously
that's private land and we did they did
put forward an option that did look at
moving the pep the path further south
but as you can see in some of the plans
the putting green on the um Golf Course
is is right up against the edge of this
um of the tree so if you go further
south it will impact on
um the golf course and the location of
those putting greens and they will have
to sort of be on board to allow the path
to go there through across that their
land and
um sort of redesigns the putting greens
to to accommodate it so it was a bit of
a tricky one I'm not sure I'm not sure
where Casey got to on that because they
did go to a meeting which I didn't
actually attend talking with them about
it
um obviously they didn't get very far
because we've come in with this
application that isn't looking at
putting the path and the passing green
um but it is looking at the the part the
location that results in the least
number of trees being removed so yes we
did you know I raised concerns when we
initially looking at it it's an area
that we would want to see
um trees retained and the
um areas for wildlife retained but at
the same time I mean I personally from
walking along there know that it's it's
quite tricky as you go around the corner
because it's on a Bend as well so in
terms of Public Safety if you're coming
up the road you're coming around and
you've got no footpath along there so
it's it's quite difficult that you're
trying to look around the corner for
traffic oncoming traffic and there's
just no no footpath so up yeah it was it
was something that we felt was was
beneficial for um for the public
I think for that ever
um councilor wing
I I mean I think we all agree that
pedestrian safety is is Paramount really
and also we need to consider the loss of
trees but I mean I don't walk that route
but I've cycled that route and what I
can't understand is why we would spend
money or somebody would spend money on
creating a footpath that is only to be
used by people on foot and that that
cyclists still have to go into the main
road which is still very dangerous for
cyclists on on that on that stretch up
there is a very dangerous stretch of the
road so I I can't I don't understand it
seems to me that we've just got this
thing that isn't really fulfilling uh
what it really needs to fulfill which is
the protection of of people on bikes and
pedestrians mums and dads were push
chairs and making the assumption that if
it's not capable for a bike what does a
parent do with a double buggy or a or a
large person on a Mobility Scooter so I
don't it doesn't seem to be well thought
through to to begin with uh and then you
have got the loss of the trees which is
also concerning that's what I'd say I
won't support this although we need a
safe route there yeah yeah
just again I appreciate I apologies for
sort of like repetition of earlier um I
think it's it's that for KCC to do it
and to have it be a combined cycle and
pedestrian root has to be wider for
safety in terms of conflict between
cyclists I know I know
um I mean in terms of uh you know there
is the provision for I think the width
of a double buggy and it's it is tricky
because there is no perfect solution
here there's no that there is no think
nothing that doesn't impact on the trees
um uh you know and the vegetation there
um and therefore that's why it is it is
a balance
um I think that the concern from
officers perspective is
um normally what if if the motion were
to fall because the member's concerns
what you know we would suggest is
obviously further discussion with Casey
about any alternatives Etc but we
wouldn't I think necessarily be likely
to be able to come back with anything
that's any different
um but I can't speak to that necessarily
but I think they have tried to
accommodate all the different conflicts
that you've got there with both the golf
course and the operation of that the
loss of trees
Etc
um so um but I leave it to members
thank you councilor Hall
thank you chair I've written very
intently to the conversations had round
here and I'd like to know who owns the
land is it KCC land or is it golf course
land
um we understand that uh Kingsgate
Castle are in the corner
um but if it's if it's Council land
um my concern is I would rather see uh
an a home Oak destroyed and cut down
because they really are weeds in most
people's ideas
um it's not a decent Oak anyway
um I'd rather see that cut down and have
ladies safety decently looked after
because it's right by the road and lit
and can be seen then having to go into
an era which is 60 80 feet long possibly
I don't know how long it is where they
feel at risk and I think for the sake of
a tree or two trees I would rather see
something which is more appealing to the
safety aspect of the ladies concerns
we've all mentioned it and for for
anybody else who has concerns for their
safe 50 and I I think that just because
we're going to go around a tree and put
somebody's
um safety at risk I think it's a bit um
immature really thank you uh thank you
Council Hart yes yes I'm doing well
tonight thank you that's that so
um the land obviously mentioned about
the triangle which has been mentioned
since of kings and Castle residence so
the the reason this is coming to
planning committee is because we own the
land in terms of the golf course
obviously there's a lease involved in
terms of the golf course and operation
they that's why the reason why it's
before members this evening
um
I again I think in terms of
um it's not been put forward with any
lighting obviously again local Wildlife
site
um it's an area which you know you would
potentially want to be dark to avoid any
particular ecological impact but
admittedly we do not know if there's any
investigation of a level of low-level
lighting again it will likely be you
know potentially maybe a limitation on a
budgetary basis I do not know but
obviously it's been put forward on the
basis as it is which is obviously is
identical to the one that's obviously to
to the South thank you uh thank you Ian
Council Keane
thank you it isn't perfect but I know
this bit of road and it is extremely
dangerous and I think on balance that
there needs to be a footpath so I will
support it
uh thank you councilor bayford
sorry uh just quickly um I might have
missed it but
the proposed width of the new footpath
is it the same as the existing footpath
further down
I I can't confirm I know it's 1.5 meters
wide
but I but yeah I I think I think that
looking at that joke sorry I can
actually sit on this plan sorry it
indicates that the footpath that's there
that is wider that's why it's it's it
goes seems to be 1.8 to 3 meters which
is why you've got the cycle chicanes to
go back onto the road because that is a
cycle you know it's a cycle I mean you
know I've used the one that's there
from time to time and it's perfectly big
enough wide enough for families for push
chairs things like that but I wouldn't
use it at night to be honest I can't
I can't people would need to use it at
night it's not an area where people
would need to travel at night on foot
uh thank you thank you that Council both
counselor effort
yeah I mean whilst I understand people's
concerns about using using these
footpaths on their own at night not
everybody is on their own and not
everybody is using it at night and
actually I find the existing footpath
because which I also use as a cyclist
probably quite dangerous for pedestrians
because of the speed which cyclists can
move through it and it's not
particularly wide so I think we all have
to make our own judgments but what I do
know is that that road is dangerous
um we've got a footpath in front of us
it's not perfect
um we've not been able to find a perfect
solution I have enough confidence in the
officers who've Put It Forward from KCC
and everyone has been involved they've
tried to find a solution I think a new
footpath is better than no footpath and
I will vote for it thank you thank you
Council over it and I know I won't be
walking down the path when you're riding
your bike okay
um I'm going to draw a line there
members
um
last one counseling
thank you I just want to go back to
councilor Hart said who owns the land so
so we are the landlords of the whole
golf course and I think we're 100 agreed
that we need a footpath uh we have an
issue over is the footpath for cyclists
is it for pedestrians we have an issue
over the removal of the trees but we are
the landlords of a huge amount of
grassland so like any landlord can't we
just have some conversations with our
tenants to say we have got some safety
measures we need to put in place and
negotiate bringing the footpath through
through the land as I think's been
suggested behind to to to further reduce
the impact on the uh on on the removal
of trees and Hedgerow home Oaks might
not be very nice trees to look at in
your opinion but they are habitats and a
lot of things living there so it seems
to me me that we have we have we we
agree we need a footpath I think that's
unanimous within this room uh what we
disagree on is maybe where the footpath
should be and I think there should be
some further exploration because there
needs to be because we still need a bat
survey to look at an alternative
footpath that involves coming through
the golf course which is land we own
I think Counseling in just briefly I
must admit I it's it's a matter for
Estates what the terms of the lease are
and imagine it's incredibly long lease
and I don't know necessarily that the
council would have the authority to
unilaterally disrupt the golf course I
can't speak to it but fundamentally the
the
The Proposal is obviously what's on the
table if if it were to fall then it
allows for other options to be
investigated but at the same time as I
outlined there is always going to be a
bit of a balance here between the
different conflicts that you've got with
the the minimal space that that's there
thank you thank you
okay members okay uh very good
discussion and debate there um so kind
of put it to you
are you the hot Council on
I can't possibly comment again I can't
sort of
um
members I'm going to put this to you
which is obviously for approval those in
favor
and me
for
those against
this is called
what's happening at six over or seven
six six is four there two yep
um
members that has been approved yes
yes four four four
okay it's a four six
should we
just bring it we will we'll do it again
just just to be absolutely clear yeah
um
we'll do it again
um
right I will ask to have a hand cut
those in favor please show
okay those against
abstentions
that is carried thank you members and
the savior totally understand the
concerns they are thank you
write that concludes public speaking for
this meeting I will call on now Clark
Stephen to read out the remaining
planning applications if a member wishes
to reserve the application please will
they let me know so
a country agenda 4f for approval number
six we have 19 Church Road Ramsgate
Council crinton
okay uh
uh item four h for approval number eight
sixty Northumberland Avenue Margate
okay nope uh item 4i for approval number
nine 71 West Thompson Lane Ramsgate
and item 4J uh Charlotte is that one
Fortune no one yeah yep item 4J four
approval number ten the garage blocks at
Tobin Drive Margate
okay
okay so it's uh just the one
19 Church Road
yes so the applications not reserved for
debate can I have a proposed to move
those applications have not been
reserved determined in accordance with
the office's recommendations
and a proposal please thank you Council
Auburn seconder
counts uh shrub the members agree
thank you for the benefit of the public
if we have any left I will call upon the
clock just to read out the applications
that have been determined thank you
okay item 4f for approval number six 19
Church Road Ramsgate
reserved by councilor Christian
oh sorry sorry I do apologize uh the
other items uh 4H for proof of number
eight is 16 Northampton Avenue Margate
uh item 4i for approval number nine 71
West dumpton Lane Ramsgate item 4J for
approval number 10 garage blocks at
Tomlin Drive Market
thank you thank you right it's Emma
please Emma
thank you chairman um the application
site is is outlined here in red it's in
the Ramsgate Conservation Area you can
see uh Church Road
um in this location here
and then just an aerial view of the site
so again this is the application site
here
and you can see Church Road in this
location here so this is the front
elevation of the existing building so
it's a single dwelling
um you can see it within the front
elevation at ground floor level
um our slided sash Timber windows
um you can see in this photo as well the
um
original
um sort of Steels that would have were
around the Gap so this was originally an
opening to drive through to a yard at
the rear so it was originally to do with
a Timber yard and this would have been
the access through so through a previous
application when it's been turned into a
residential unit this has been
um the the window and brick work that's
in filled this space so the actual
Windows themselves are not original to
the building they've just been in
addition when that change of use took
place
this as a closer view of the window so
they are quite traditional looking being
sliding Sash and Timber and therefore
they do they do currently fit in with
the the character of the Conservation
Area
and here you can see some wider views of
the neighboring properties
um I mean this one's got upvc to the
right hand side but again you can see
there's generally sliding sash designs
in the the locality and again another
view of the um buildings within the road
you can see there's a variety of
different building styles within the
robe again most of them are very
traditional and therefore is accepted
that the the windows are currently in
place are are in keeping with the area
um but as as mentioned they aren't the
original windows so this is a side
elevation of the building you can see
there's a an existing Window and Door
this is the existing entrance into the
building so this is a shared space so
you can see the entrance to the
neighboring property as well
um I know both both access from this
this area
um and then this is the existing floor
plan and then this is the proposed so
you can see the in terms of the changes
on the left hand elevation the current
door which is in this location here is
is being turned into a window
and being the doors being fixed so
to create a fixed feature in this
location here this is existing and then
this is a new window that's being added
with Timber frames and then to the front
elevation those existing windows are
being removed at ground floor level and
been replaced with the new entrance door
so the aim of this is to create entrance
from the front rather than an entrance
from that that side elevation
and then this is the existing elevation
plan so again you can see the existing
windows at ground floor level and then
these this is a proposed plan so these
are
um Timber effect doors this this door on
the left is the actual opening door
these are two fixed panels with Windows
within but it gives the impression of
um by folding panels that open
so in terms of the conservation area
it's felt that whilst the original
windows are in keeping with the
conservation area this is actually
potentially an enhancement because it
actually draws on the historic character
of the building and the fact that this
was originally an access and an outlet
that led to the yard at the rear and
that's how the the building was
originally built as you can see from
those Stills and supports that are
visible within the flight elevation so
this actually draws from the historic um
context of the building and puts in
place something that is is more in
keeping with its historic use
um again it's Tim bass which is in
keeping with the conservation area and
the doors are of a design that is
considered to be appropriate and not no
concerns are raised with the
conservation officer
then within the side elevation so again
this is the existing elevation so you
can see the existing window and the door
in this location here and then this is
now how it would be with the new window
being inserted in this location which
again is is Timber framed and then this
is been
um fixed so it's no longer an opening
door it's it has the appearance of a
door but would actually just be serving
as a window into that space
so again there's there's no real
concerns from from the change of the
access
um and the fact that the
um windows or Timber are is considered
appropriate in terms of any impact to
neighbors this additional window is
intended to be obscure glazed with some
stained glass
um uh with details of this were
submitted as part of the application
different ideas of how it could be
stained glass could be used with it and
that will prevent any overlooking in
towards that space but in any case it's
not a private space it's just the shared
entrance serving the other units and in
terms of the front front doors again
there's no impact to neighbors so it is
recommended for approval on the basis
that we do actually consider that the
proposed Works would be an enhancement
given the historic use of the building
thank you uh thank you Emma once again I
move that the officer's recommendation
be adopted by share please second oh
second nature thank you Council common
cook members cancer Crittenden thank you
um the reason that I wanted this
considered is because whilst I hear the
comments about the original use of the
building
um the threefold doors is now completely
out of keeping with the other frontages
along the rest of the road as you can
see from the photograph that was shown
earlier and given that it's a
conservation area that is what I wanted
members to consider
uh thank you are they threefolding doors
Emma or is it
um no mommy asking you the the door on
the left is a door and then the other
two are yeah imitation doors but they
actually will be fixed so
um as mentioned as you can see in this
elevation or this photo here there is a
variety of different building styles
within the street and whilst it's
accepted that the windows that are
currently within the building are in
keeping with what's within the street
you have to consider the historic use of
this building and the fact that this had
um an opening there originally and was
originally an access and didn't have
Windows there
I think that just has to be considered
as to whether what's proposed is
actually more appropriate and actually
makes it a bit more unique in the
conservation area drawing on the history
rather than just something that ties in
with with other buildings
thank you does any other member wish to
speak
nope
are you awake
thank you members uh right I put this to
you
those in favor of this application
please show
those against
that has been carried I'm sorry sorry
counseling an abstention
thank you members
thank you very much for your time
tonight and once again good discussions
on the applications
and it's all around to council shrubs
house now for a birthday drink
thank you to the officers and Steve and
then take care good night